[Music]  it's time for et social study your quick  look at what the stars are posting  online Eva Longoria interrupted her  tropical getaway with her hubby to  confirm she's not pregnant  Nick Carter became a dad to his son  exactly a year ago he posted this  adorable snap wishing little Odin a  happy first birthday it's an amazing  experience and he's definitely  brightened up our lives also celebrating  a birthday Miranda Kerr  her ex Orlando Bloom shared this  thoughtful message praising the model as  an amazing mother co-parent and friend  but they're not the only friendly exes  in town Jennifer Lopez continues to  collab with her former flame Marc  Anthony the duo are hard at work in the  studio  [Music]  speaking of hard work check out Luke  Evans in beastmode at the gym and  adorable  here's Paris Jackson hugging her pals  stranger things star Millie Bobby Brown  hashtag friendship goals  [Music]